agent so this is the TOC the Tactical
Operations Center I figured we could use
a spot away from all the sips we got
upstairs to plan a stage operations
every Intel feed we got I patched into
the system down here and put together
the bandwidth to analyze the raw data if
there's any tactical Intel the squeeze
from this [ __ ] I'll find it
speaking of which bring that smartphone
over the ops Faneuil good thing about
having the face of operations here is
we've got a massive rail network right
beneath our feet I finally got a couple
of cars operational that's how you're
gonna get around nice work on my part if
I do say so myself
the meal in the Rika's location agent
getting out of comms range the deeper
you go the heart of time I'll have to
keep in tracking you good luck in there
alert how detecting hostiles jamming
device
jamming device
area secure
Elad hostiles detected
a lot of disabled
very secure
the end is nigh clever we're sure when
we moved in
anything Goods all yours don't start the
party until you hear a real Big Bang
this is not like division what's your
con sounds like you don't trust me
[ __ ] no I don't trust you but I like
what you're offering I just know there's
no such thing as a free lunch no catch
it's just that it's a whole new world
now and we all have to make new friends
have fun with that
morning pastels a bit detected
whatever you found down there we need it
back in the TOC ASAP